huge tour announcement calling on all
the army of garbage we just added a
bunch of dates to the state tracking
door for the fall and for the winter
stand-up comedy show plus we play a
little ayg with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show come
out and see the boys yeah gang all
tickets are available at our website Ru
garbage.com uh we're coming to Phoenix
Denver Salt Lake City Los Angeles San
Diego Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Toronto Pontiac Michigan Chicago
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
San Francisco San Jose and then we're
ending it in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
maybe get those tickets let's party
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grew up to be classy or to just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at hoodies in
the new edition I just saw her out on
the street okay driving a lawnmower all
right going on a highway sure my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
that's a quick one this week thought I'd
get him did not succeed give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are cooking
then the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com gang check it the [__]
out it's a party over there yeah I love
that patreon having a nice quick shout
out to our producer X Jordan Air the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours crosses the t's and he dots the
eyes give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
it's Toby McMullen everybody for God's
sakes what's up boys we got a sharp dude
in there here we go and if I do say to
myself he might be the guy to fix the
goddamn potholes in this city
he can get he can get some [__] going
this guy getting it done gang the long
hair ain't lying because we couldn't be
more excited to have her incredibly and
I mean incredibly special guests here
with this today for the first time he is
a founding member of the amazing amazing
Legion of skanks and the host of part of
the problem very funny stand-up comedian
podcaster and currently number 687 on
the CIA kill list
give it up for Dave Smith everybody
oh thank you very much this is uh hey
pal I'm looking around at amazement like
this is what happens when you unwed
yourself from Louisville
it's uh have I been doing it wrong how
dare you
shout out to Mr Louis J Gomez digital so
tell me about this patreon website
there's there's money involved we pay
them
buddy thank you so much for coming in
man absolutely thank you for having me
we're excited You've Been Everywhere
lately it seems uh give us the back
story give us give us the rundown
Brooklyn kid if I recall right yes
Brooklyn Born and Raised born in
Brooklyn in the 80s and 90s okay so not
like you know today Brooklyn it's not
today it evokes a whole different like
image when people say it today what
neighborhood did you grow up I grew up
in Park Slope okay uh and then Prospect
Heights okay I moved around there I
moved a lot like I lived in uh excellent
I lived in I'm just never classy well it
was just with my mom I lived in I'm
trying to count it up there's okay one
two three four five six [__]
I mean there were a couple levels up in
there but none never drastic but then
that was that was by the time I went off
to college I think we were at nine and
then she moved like seven more times
after that so I'm going to be coming
home to visit it'd always be like a
different place
what is this place there were a few
there were divorces in there that were
part of the moves sure but those only
accounted for two yeah there was a nine
divorces the rest was I mean I'm not
even exactly we this is true so I moved
from 12th Street between 6th and 7th
Avenue to 11th Street between 6th and
7th Avenue Jesus but you're like why why
did we even do it the answer to three
things what are you gonna do yeah like
it was like why are we even carrying our
stuff over here was it you was it
monetarily things like couldn't cover
the rent or no it was like she was
dating a guy in the building and they
broke up and so she wanted to get out of
the building uh this guy went on but not
too far well this guy went on to be my
stepfather so it's like they got back
together really well she only made it a
block away you know like that's not
enough time
think I was gonna find you I gotta skip
it there was no Trader Joe's yeah a nice
Key Food is that what it was key Foods
uh a key food and a dagostino and let me
tell you when D'Agostino first came in
oh man we were hyped yeah we were like
yo we just moved up yeah that's like a
trip to Sicily oh yeah it was all right
it was incredible day so did Food
Emporium in New York yes they had a
moment yeah they I don't I didn't have
any of those by me but I had bitten to
them like at my father's house he lived
in Manhattan and it was like now we're
stepping up you know yeah can we go to
Food Emporium yeah all right this is
this is cereal hold on so back this up a
little bit do you have any brothers and
sisters yeah I got an older sister and a
younger brother same mom and dad no my
younger brother's a half brother from
with my stepfather okay but my sister is
yeah same mom and dad so your mom and
dad got married yes had you and your
older sister yes not in that order all
right so then it's so sephoria you're in
an apartment in Brooklyn
uh no my mother so when I was like okay
the weeds already when I was a baby uh
we lived in um in an apartment in
Brooklyn Heights okay and then they
buried they bought a house in Park Slope
okay now all these neighborhoods weren't
quite what they are what they are now of
course you know like they weren't like
you know like horrible because it means
Brooke but yeah yeah no no no it wasn't
East uh it wasn't East New York
but it wasn't like what you might think
of it now it was very like sure you get
a real affordable home and stuff there
but so they bought a brownstone in Park
Slope okay so that was from when I was
one to like three and a half and then
they got divorced and
he went to Manhattan what did your mom
and dad do for a living at the time uh
at the time my dad it was never really
been clear what to do oh Jesus Christ
amen if you were to listen to a lot of
trips to Dallas in the 60s yeah if you
were to listen to him tell it at the
time he was like uh he he was running
like an advertising company okay okay
but there was junk man there was very
little evidence that this company
existed
and my dad was a uh habitual liar sure
so you never really knew what was up
with him
um that was one of the issues my mom had
with him sure
you're lying to me constantly yeah but
he could swing a brownstone that's
pretty nice no matter what decade it is
yes he was able he he well it's we never
exactly figured it out but I think he
got a little bit of money from like my
grandfather got remarried later in life
like in his 90s to some old broad who
had a little bit of money like she was
married to a wealthy guy you come from a
[__] linear yeah
there's a lot of trash in this whole
story
um but uh so we don't really know
exactly but yeah he figured that out uh
what was your mom doing for work my mom
was uh she was going back to school okay
she like was going back to get like her
Masters I think he's learning from what
I understand right my mom's very smart
very very smart uh so she was swinging
it at the time your dad was the one
paying the bills yeah
but my dad was like also like he'd be
like the worst stickler like he would
like refuse to pay bills and then like
threaten to sue them
easy [__] like my mom my mom how come I
turn your power off how about me it was
like that it was but he was like he had
no shame he went to like a dentist and
then they did a bunch of work on him
yeah he was he was like I'm gonna shut
this whole place down and it was like
okay fine we'll just call it even or
whatever he's like you're lucky I'm
letting you off easy
with a warning here my mom would you
know just be like mortified and she's
like that dentist is a friend of mine
like what are you doing right but oh man
but he was yes my mother wasn't bringing
in any money we had that my dad was
paying for whatever was he was the
breadwinner okay and then so they get
divorced when you're three you move out
of the Brownstone move out of the
Brownstone moved into a uh
um a basement apartment of a of a
brownstone are you aware that this is a
step down at the at the age you were I
was aware there's a lot less space
around you know
[Music]
now everything seems to be happening in
one room
but uh we were real real broke but I was
not I didn't I don't think I was aware
of it until like like as I started
getting older like at the time I was
just like we eat scrambled eggs for
dinner a lot that's pretty pretty sweet
yeah there's no problem sure it was like
I think when I started realizing we were
real broke was uh when we'd go to like
birthday parties I remember this that we
could never get good presents
forever my friends or whoever's birthday
we were going to and we used to get you
remember they used to have like travel
toys you know what I'm talking about
like it would be like a trap like
instead of like Monopoly it'd be like
traveling
so like it'd be like a little mini board
of checkers yeah like [__] like that is
what we'd always get and I started to
put that together then I'm like what
that's weird like no one else has given
mini presents out
dude thanks for the map of Cleveland
okay all right there that's really good
I know that's
man that's all right all right so does
your dad dip out of the picture
completely at this point you've seen him
uh very sporadically okay you know so
like I'd see him they'd work out like a
schedule then he'd [__] bail or
something so it was it was like it was
fine for those years like it was I would
see him and I'd be like I'm going to
Dad's house okay at this time but it
wasn't like a regular it wasn't like you
know oh he's got me half the time or
something like that they're popping into
Manhattan Thursday to Sunday yeah none
of that after that all right so for a
period for a period I was doing every
Friday at his house every Friday I'd go
there would your sister go with you too
yeah we both go and then come back uh
Saturday morning it's really not very
long
uh but but that and that didn't last
consistently for very long so there's
happy hours over there yeah he's gonna
leave Saturday morning what the [__] it
was it was like nothing it made no sense
it was just an inconvenience for
everybody involved like no one got
anything out of it Wednesday at seven to
Thursday at two all right so it's you
your mom and your sister you guys are
over there in Brooklyn
um
all right what was a family vacation
like yeah what would you do with that we
um sure and did you guys have did she
have her family around [__]
she's uh yes she was but her her parents
had like moved out they were living in
Suffern
uh at the time okay which is I can't
remember if that's Upstate or in Jersey
but Suffern I think New York I think
it's I think I feel like yeah I would
know if that was German it was like a
little you know kind of trashy like old
person area yeah like Upstate New York
not too far I think doesn't sound great
it wasn't great no uh that we did we had
a couple we didn't go on vacation like
every year but we did we went to um back
then Montauk used to be like the real
cheap affordable option really yeah the
Hamptons were like already crazy but if
you were willing to go out to Montana so
much further it's not easy to get there
yes so we would we did that a couple
times you guys were like first to Market
and all the places that are nice now
it's well it's crazy I almost have to
say it because you're like I mean first
off there's a weird thing about this
show that makes you want to be garbage
oh yeah like you come in here and you're
like you're gonna tell me I'm not
garbage I'm garbage what are we talking
about which is so bizarre and nothing
anyone should strive yeah welcome to the
party baby but if you just say like Park
Slope and Montauk it sounds like oh were
you guys Millionaires and you're like no
it wasn't like yeah that wasn't the the
deal yeah but so yeah we did things like
that but nothing else crazy my father
took me a few times down to uh Miami
because his father had retired drive or
fly down there we did some drugs
your dad sounds like a driver he's like
why would I spend my time he was weird
like he was so cheap but he would always
spin it as like look I'm a genius
what am I an idiot these suckers are
paying 79 bucks to fly around shreds
three days yeah like right I can get
there and [__] you know 60 hours for
12 minutes I think I'm paying the tolls
yeah
when I get there I'm telling him I'm
suing him if he doesn't let me and my
son through it was hey Dave you got to
drive through North Carolina all right
like he uh I remember him taking me out
like a couple times to advance like a
decent restaurant and he'd tell me
before we went there I'm gonna cause a
scene
he goes
I want you to fake a heart attack when
they bring the dessert menu he probably
did a couple times he really did cause
the scene but uh but he used to say
before we'd get there he'd go look
don't order any sides
they get you on the sides
he's like that's how they get you
so you just order an entree
that's how you win Dad [__] call
right there like your dad for sure
thought he had people after him yeah
yeah yeah and then like as you get older
you're like it's not like a trick it's
just if you want other stuff you have to
pay for it also and it's so nice to get
sides with your food but he's like
that's how you beat the system is you
eat your chicken with no potatoes
all right you don't need mixed
vegetables just imagine looking down to
it imagine looking down to one of your
kids at like six being like listen that
asparagus is a rip-off all right dude
I've overcompensated it should be not my
dad I am the mo I am the least jewy Jew
in the world like I over
it's literally every everything I'm like
do you want more sides get more sides I
don't want to ruin you bring all the
cream spinach out right now okay okay
and so what did your mom start doing as
she got her Masters well she was uh so
she she got uh psychology is like was
her her field so she got her Masters and
then her PhD in Psychology and then she
had she got like uh she got like a job
jobs while she was doing that okay
um in the field or just whatever yeah
yeah she was uh one of her jobs that she
had for a long time was she was uh so I
don't want to give out like too much
but the job was basically that she would
like uh she was the head of like a
child's unit and would like evaluate
kids gotcha who were like abused and
[__] like that and then make uh like a
recommendation whether these kids got to
be taken away from them she was out
there doing it she was making a
difference yeah real dark making like
crap money and uh and and but out there
you know dealing with this crazy [__]
and then at a certain point I guess when
I was in uh maybe like the ninth grade
she opened uh a private practice making
really good money but you know she went
from like she her track was like making
24 Grand a year for dealing with like
okay well there's three cigar burns on
this child right what do you think we
should do and then it was like for like
24 Grand a year and then it was like or
for 200 000 a year you could listen to
like some rich lady who's like I don't
feel good about me yeah you know yeah
like yeah and you're like wow I
understand why you chose the ladder sure
you know yeah sure all right so she's
doing that you're doing okay uh where
was where was that place where was that
apartment so at this point
um we're the the last place where I was
was on uh Sterling Place in uh Prospect
Heights okay so that's where I lived for
like the the high school years
um and her and my stepfather got married
had my baby brother okay and that's when
she started to like make a little bit of
money all right like do a little bit
better so now we got a little family
unit you're starting High School uh are
you going to public school you going
private I went to private school at this
point I was going I went to public
school for a while went to ps107 okay
then I went to uh to Berkeley Carroll my
mom got my dad to cough up the money
there you go and that from somewhere
probably played none of us nowhere
probably played mind games on them and
it was a now she had a a constant thing
with the school that we were late on
payments they would always be it'd
always be like uh you're like three
years behind and we're gonna kick you
out if you don't I was always about to
get kicked out of high school for my
reasons and for my dad not paying him
which is Dave Smith kid he's not even
paying goddamn bills and I was [__]
doing terrible in school I was causing
all types of problems I was really
really bad uh student like I was I was a
terrible student and also just a pain in
the ass I was going to say I was a
really bad kid but I wasn't like
shooting people or anything sure I was
uh cursing out teachers yeah you didn't
have any sides yeah I had no nutrients
to get them from the size how bad of a
student are we talking what were your
what were your SAT scores I did I did
okay on this you're a smart guy yeah
yeah I did I did okay on the SATs and I
didn't prep for them and I also didn't
finish them you got a number I literally
it was 12 something
yeah it's 12 it was 12 something and I
didn't I mean I think I came pretty
close to finishing well I think it was
like 20 Questions left and I was like
I'm [__] out of here I don't know I
was like an add Stoner I was like I
can't do this anymore I need to go run
around you're judged on what you make it
to right or I don't know I think like if
I would have known that I would answer
three questions
I don't know if you're right about that
but maybe maybe that's true um but so I
did I did okay on the SATs which is how
I got into a shitty school because my
grades were I I literally I always did
did whatever it was I think it was a c
minus you had to have before they'd kick
you off the basketball team and so I
always got that you're shooting exactly
that was my big thing I cared about and
so I'd always get except one one year I
did get kicked off because I didn't I
like you know I was always trying to get
just that last thing and then I like
didn't get up to that and I was like ah
[__] at a d plus average or something
and they were like they're like you're
kicked off the team and I was like you
guys were serious about that I thought
it was just like a thing we say now when
we say private school it was what what
like League or whatever was it was you
was it Yeshiva was it a Jewish school no
no no it was just like a regular uh
private I don't know if the league was
just like the other it wasn't a Catholic
School no not Catholic okay no religious
okay radiation uh they were like like I
kind of woke before there was woke
gotcha school but back then you know
what it really wasn't so bad it was in
the 90s yeah it was almost just being
like hey if you see like a lesbian don't
spit on her you know
a little video's been going around from
the 80s when they tell them
in a pickup facing forward in the cars
yeah they're like they're like ma'am
there's a baby in this car and you're
like this car in America yeah where you
can drink who's supposed to hold the
wheel
man the one guy does really sell it to
Jose it's getting to the point now where
a man can't work a hard 10-12 hour day
and have a cold beer on the way home
that guy's not wrong no the guy and
actually like that guy makes you go like
oh man I bet that beer is the best yeah
whatever that guy's life is when he
cracks open that first cold beer I think
few of us experience something as great
as well
yeah ice probably ice cold it's sitting
in a cooler all day okay let's talk
about bass bass boost yeah we're talking
about the best bags in the biz baby
traveling stinks sure does you know what
I mean you get to the airport you got
this you got that you got to deal with
DSA the last thing you need is a bad
roller bag like looking like a doofus no
kidding gang do yourself a favor get
over the base you got tons of pockets
360 degree gliding Wheels a built-in
weight indicator don't say nothing and a
nice cushion handle yeah uh they were
nice enough the good people at Bay sent
us the Weekender bag that has a place
for your shoes at the bottom and you
know as you know about me Kippy likes a
nice pair of shoes sure I take a couple
out with me I throw them in the bottom
of that zigzag Zoom I'm cruising uh not
only bases have all your packing needs
cover but the bags also look incredible
they come in tons of sizes and colors uh
it made to look even better with you so
you can Chuck it in that overhead
without the overhead compartment without
wiring right now base is offering our
listeners 15 off your first purchase by
visiting basetravel.com garbage that's
b-e-i-s travel.com garbage go to
basedravel.com garbage for 15 off your
first purchase maybe shout out to base
do it okay let's talk about Faker Victor
Victor let's talk about one of our
favorites Factor pre-made meals gang the
summer
The Summer's busy uh-huh right you got
things to do you gotta drop the kids off
here you gotta run here you gotta run
there
you know what's awesome if you can make
dinner lunch real quick easy peasy and
it was healthy and good for you with
Factor meals you can do that you pop it
in the microwave two minutes comes out
absolutely delicious we talk about them
all the time I know big fan I I'm a pan
man myself I do them on a frying pan
about 90 seconds slopping on a plate
bada bang bada boom grab my diet coke
I'm out the door uh whether you're
counting calories looking to boost boost
protein intake or have a specific
dietary lifestyle Factor has you covered
with over 34 weekly meal options to
choose from like grilled Steakhouse
filet mignon Green Goddess chicken
there's always something new to try they
ain't lying baby I'll go on I pick what
I like bada bing bada boom I'm a chilly
man myself just saying and the
factor75.com garbage50 and use code
garbage 50 to get 50 off Jesus that's
code garbage 50 at factor75.com garbage
50 to get 50 off uh do it gang show me
you love them there you go man uh-huh
all right what was that High School
mascot uh the I don't think we had a
mascot the team was the Lions okay but
we didn't have like a guy yeah the team
was the lions that was their an actual
lion it's different back then we've lost
three of our starters
this lion is hungry there's a locker
room whose idea was this can't you get a
kid in a costume for God's sake
okay all right then you go to school
where'd you go to college I went to
Hartwick College which has been uh
Oneonta New York okay it's like uh it's
right across from the Sunni Oneonta
school okay uh which uh I was there for
uh about a year and a half
no and then the last the last half I
wasn't I mean I was there but I wasn't
in college in any sense I stopped going
to all of my classes nice and I was just
like riding it out okay like just yeah
just just there to drink and [__] the
only thing worse than the only the only
college kid worse than that kid is a kid
who's not enrolled anymore but still
living on campus yeah what are you doing
yeah I know there's always a few like
that it was a cool I kind of like I had
fun I think I had a good amount of fun
my first semester there and then it was
like winter hit and Oneonta winter is
like probably brutal oh it's horrible
dude I've seen the 80s and 90s yeah well
this is this is the comfort of this
global warming back before coats
well this is
like 2002.80s yeah he was [__] yeah
no this this point is not the 80s
anymore like you know it's like Eminem
Eight Mile was out or something like
that
I got it was like hard I'm pushing your
protests in the Vietnam War
we'll bring our boys home when they
finish the job
um but so I was just like horribly
depressing Winters and I really hated it
I just missed the city so what was the
big thought you're like I only drop out
I'm gonna go do what like what were you
gonna what was the payment how did you
sell it to your mom like I'm dropping
out of college oh no I didn't sell it
you just did it yeah yeah I didn't have
a plan or anything I was like I can't be
here anymore
um so I just uh yeah I just I left you
did yeah and you go back to her
apartment did you get an apartment in
the City by yourself and start working I
got I went back to her apartment for a
little bit and then I got got a place so
you never went back to school no really
okay College Dropout gotcha smartest guy
I know literally true well I uh I None
of I didn't learn anything from school I
mean I I suppose like I learned things
like when I was a little kid in school
and I learned like a few random things
that I know in school but nothing that I
know about comes from school it's all
like from [__] like learning [__]
after that yeah so what was the job job
that you got when you went back were you
like I'm gonna go start waiting tables
or so this is uh so this is how uh I
meet Louis J Gomez oh he started this
out yeah and that's how I got in the
comedy no actually I knew Lewis uh had
been dating a friend of my sisters what
man that kid gets around yeah he's all
right the kid's been closing Plus for
decades yeah yeah we only found this out
when we were mapping HPV and we realized
it went back to uh we're like okay well
you go to the source which is Louis J
Gomez
what's up doggies
so he
ljg so yes so he was doing this uh he
was working for this company called new
genesis
and they were selling tickets for uh the
comic strip
and so I went there I interviewed for
the job at the comic strip
had you thought about being a comic at
this point no never you were just
looking for a job I was a huge fan of
stand-up comedy as a kid like I was I it
was like anything that was stand up I
would anytime I was on Comedy Central
I'd always watch it anytime there was a
DVD or not DVD I guess VHS and I rent it
from Blockbuster or whatever
um so it's a huge fan of stand-up comedy
but I didn't even know it was like a
thing like when I first got the job
you're like a comedy club like there's
just comedy clubs around and there's
like and so that was my first
introduction to like oh just like
regular like people do this you can go
do it on a Tuesday night and that it's
not celebrities it's not just like Eddie
Murphy and Jerry Seinfeld do this like
Pete you know there's just like this guy
uh and so I interviewed for the job when
I say interview for the jump they give
the job to everyone there's no interview
process like do you have yeah you have
two legs yeah all right you can make
this work uh and so I started doing that
um and it was uh it was actually at the
time it was at the time it was a really
fun job it was like a summer job it's
over in Times Square handing out they're
doing tickets we'd go all over the city
and you were selling the tickets not
just like handing them out like you had
to get someone to give you money
um but it was it was all like young
people who were doing it they were all
like around my age like college kids and
it was like so that kind of like became
our crew and we'd all like get drunk and
high together and party and then and you
actually make like for at the time like
great money and you'd be making like you
know like if you did if you did good you
could make like a couple hundred bucks a
day if you had a bad day you make like
50 60 bucks or something but it was
still like kind of like oh whatever yeah
this is [__] cash in my pocket you're
doing that what five days a week yeah I
would do it seven days a week sometimes
it just depends they go out every day so
you could go you could go however much
you wanted to so don't it'd usually be
like oh if you made enough money for the
week maybe I'd take a day or two off but
I just I I got along I with a lot of the
people and [__] there and then uh Lewis
left and started his own company doing
it classic Gomez well now if you could
imagine too Lewis like
Lewis was the best at that sure he was
so good he was like you were just like
yes he's in awe of him like I was pretty
good at it but nothing like Lewis like
if you could just imagine the magic of
like 22 year old Lewis Charming up
someone on the street like he was he was
hilarious with it it was so funny to
like watch him sell people and he was
just great so then he he was like the
best at the company so then he started
his own company that me and him were
already good enough friends at the time
and I was like well I'm gonna go and
basically that's been my life story ever
since it's like Lewis is like oh we're
doing this and I'm like you're doing
that then I guess I'll go do it too the
whole time he's just like we're doing
stand-up now and I was like all right I
guess we are then he's like now we're
podcasting I'm like all right he's like
now I'm starting a podcast Network and
you're like well I I've got a street
going for 15 years here so I guess I'm
going to go
I'm in baby
holy [__] holy [__] that's [__] wild
damn that is all right all righty hmm
any injuries as a kid
um no nothing like major nothing crazy
no no I never never like broke bones or
anything like never got hit by a city
bus or anything like that never got
never got hit by a city bus I did uh I I
wasn't like hurt too bad but one time we
me and my uh my what I guess we call now
ex stepbrother so my stepfather's kid uh
yeah she she used to my stepfather was
real trash uh and he was like he was
like a drunk and like uh just like a
real like a real white trash wait the
guy who your mom eventually settled with
yes okay oh they're divorced oh they're
divorced now yeah uh but they he was
like a real and he used to he was drunk
you know and so he used to he would let
us play in his car
but like like we'd be in the front seat
like we'd be like in sometimes we did
that like in the driver's seat so we'd
just be like playing like playing
yeah he'd leave and like we'd just be in
the car there and so one day me and my I
was in the passenger seat and uh my my
stepbrother at the time uh he was in the
driver's seat and I guess one of us I
don't know who did it but we were like
the this the block was kind of like on a
slope
and there was like a lot of space
between us and the next parked car and
one of us hit the Hebrew out of park
Jesus and so the car just started moving
and we're like playing this game and
then all of a sudden the car starts
rolling and we freaked out and I uh I
like uh jumped out jumped out the
passenger side I mean you know we're
going five miles an hour but I jumped
out the passenger side and I scraped up
like my the whole side of my body and
[__] and I uh at the time I thought the
car was gonna run over me because I
thought I had fallen underneath so I
started like freaking out like
hysterically crying I was like six years
old yeah and uh and then my mom ran out
and saw me and then she started
hysterically crying because she thought
like my car ran over me or something and
then I remember when she started crying
I just completely stopped crying and
looked at her and I was like what are
you crying about yeah seriously yeah and
then I kind of realized when I did I was
like oh I guess so yeah I guess I'm okay
I guess I got a little theatric with
that yeah but no no bad injuries
um were you guys practicing uh Judaism
as a kid now now no bar mitzvah I was
Bar Mitzvah but it was like other than
it was just like yeah
my wife's Jewish I can say it that is
true I guess you could say my dad my dad
was practicing he's very devouted yeah
he was great no but we did it it was
kind of like you got to do the bar
mitzvah thing yeah
yeah what'd you get do you remember I I
don't remember a couple grounds a couple
Grand look at you that's all right not
bad yeah but you didn't have anybody
who's like your grandparents gave you
like 15 grand yeah did you go to any
wild ones when you were a kid like
friends that had a little bit of cash
yeah they were insane mine was like
nothing like that like my my bar mitzvah
was at the temple like and the party was
like at the the room downstairs yeah but
they would just give you because you got
Bar Mitzvah but I went to a couple kids
who had like yeah like their wife you
know like like dance teams and [__] like
that they were like yeah that were
pretty nice I had buddies at 20 30 grand
40 Grand Paris
cash nothing like that not I remember
you were like 12 or 13 I'd be like wow I
couldn't even wrap my head around 10
grand what was the um would you do any
City kid things would you go like run
down the subway tracks or anything like
that yeah I've walked on the subway
tracks before we were big like when we
were teenagers it was a Prospect Park
was our big hangout like that's where we
went to smoke weed and drink and
Prospect is that like a CD park at the
time was it like how I would picture a
New York park it was uh back in the day
like I mean it was it was a beautiful
Park but like yeah you could you could
get jumped in the Park yeah you'd have
to you have to be worried about that
that was a big fear like as as a kid you
get jobs yeah there was like a real
thing that happened a lot and I got
jumped a few times I was gonna say we
ever take your sneakers or anything like
that never took my sneakers took my
wallet took money several times I feel
like a few guns pulled on me Jesus yeah
that was uh to go unscathed the girl
born and raised in Brooklyn it has to be
a very unique experience no no no that
didn't happen
or at least mugged at some point or
something sure yeah
um so yeah a few times like four or five
times I got mugged okay uh and uh I
think three times someone pulled a gun
on me Jesus uh
you're a sneak in the Yankee Stadium or
Shea Stadium or the Garden or anything
like that no I went to all of them but I
would I we'd get like uh you know like
nosebleeds or bleacher tickets or
something like that never snuck in
smoked weed in the old Shea Stadium a
few times that was that was cool
um but never snuck in I paid my I paid
my way I did I we did used to run on
taxi cabs that was a thing that was a
regular thing what age we talking uh 17
16. something like that it now it's it's
not it was not cool sure I feel bad
about it in hindsight uh but we used to
do when we started like uh that was a
little bit of the culture back then just
to be fair it was these cabs should have
been allowed to not take us uh but for
sure you so what we we got fake IDs like
around the time we were like 16 17 and
then we used to come into Manhattan and
try to like go to bars and [__] and uh
man Big Dreams everybody good ideas
we're gonna go downtown there was no
better things City kids City kids are
something else well you would get them
in the uh in the West Village they had
spots where you could go get these like
fake IDs and back then they would kind
of work like it wasn't like there's all
before they were digital like yeah
before there was any there wasn't being
scanned or anything like that it's just
some dude you showed it to him and he
looked at it and most of the times the
dudes back then they were kind of like I
think the pressure was like well just
let them in we want their money you know
what I mean yeah of course so we'd go
we'd get drunk in the city and then we'd
take a cab back to Brooklyn and we'd
have them drop us right in front of
Prospect Park and then the move is
there'd be like you know five of us in
the cab or whatever and what you do is
yeah you all just as soon as you get
there you all jet out and you leave the
doors open you leave every door open and
then you run into Prospect Park and so
you're just off into the night we're
teenagers you know you can run for years
like someone's Chasing You No One's
Gonna carve around the shoes does he
want to leave his car running with all
of the doors open to go chase these
scattered teenagers into the car and uh
every single time except one the answer
was no he didn't want to do that but one
time we found the wrong phone
and this [__] was in full like
sheet Garb like he was real and he was
old I mean you know when I say oh to us
at the time oh that was my age yeah you
know 40. right
um but he put up such a Chase
he was like I mean I was pretty fast
when I was a teenager like and I was
running as fast as I could through these
like Woods that I knew pretty well uh
and I remember like I could he was right
behind me and he was like and he was
screaming the whole day he was so angry
he was like I [__] your [__] I
[__] you and I'm I remember looking dude
I'm nervous now dude I was I was [__]
shook that guy I did not want to get
caught by this dude uh but I remember
looking down and I had boots on and they
were like untied like Timberland boots
that were like untied and I was
sprinting at him and I was like [__] and
as I did eventually he just gave up yeah
and then I was like oh dude if that guy
caught me but I do I did feel real and
in hindsight that's when things I feel
really
it was like a horrible thing to do
everybody has that [__] you look back on
you're like what the [__] was I thinking
at 17 18 20 whatever mid-20s you're like
like now that you have perspective and
you're older you're like what a [__]
dick move that's a little bit of a
victory for him though he did put the
fear into his oh yeah yeah oh he's
scared he's telling the story like I
scared yeah I scared this [__] lanky
white kid yeah oh yeah I made him see
Jesus he didn't have his shoes tied you
believe it I was about to [__] him
all right huh let's talk about now a
little bit sure you got the house you
got a house in Jersey nice house uh
beautiful family beautiful fam goes well
that is true you got a yard you got a
yard at the house yeah it's a single
family home right it's like a yeah yeah
there's a big house but it's on a big
property did you build this house no I
did not no not you yourself was it was
it new construction oh no it was uh it
was uh no no it was a previously owned
gotcha uh yeah you got a garage
three three-car garage
yeah I've come up in the world not part
of the problem anymore huh Dave Smith
I'm getting a lot of sides these days
[Music]
a lot of them onion rings and me
okay you got a refrigerator in the
garage
uh I have a mini fridge okay in the
garage what's in that fridge uh I think
just Waters okay right now I think it's
just like a fridge of waters because I
record I built like a studio in one of
the of the three car garage so I
converted I converted it into like a
room
um and so I just I got a mini fridge
down there in case you know okay letters
or something very nice
um how big is the backyard are we
talking an acre half an acre
like an acre and a half that's uh
it's an eight I think it's 1.8 something
for the entire property but there's like
Woods attached to that too so I don't
know exactly just like the yard area I
don't know did you throw a pool back
there is there a pool no there was no
pool and I was I was glad I didn't want
the pool okay there's just too much of a
pain in the ass it's like I I gotta I'll
end up hiring someone to take care of it
so it's just another bill I got little
kids I got like babies sure all right I
just get freaked out pools maybe down
the road but not now yes possibly who's
cutting the grass no I hire a
landscaping company they come they come
like uh once a week okay once a week
well yeah well I was they were just
coming once a month at first I'm like a
city kid so I'm figuring all this [__]
out once all right first once it was way
too long yeah I thought that would be
fine
what the dirt bags would do yes I went
once a month at first and I was like
that's more how often do you need to mow
alone I figured out pretty quickly ten
days you're like I gotta [__] get
these yeah this is really a problem
I also didn't I didn't uh there's a lot
of things I didn't know about like I
didn't know about like uh dandelions or
real [__] [__] those things really
yeah just take over and then there was
like this one period where like uh it's
like where I live is like a real nice
Street like all the houses are real nice
and there all of a sudden there's just
dandelions everywhere like my entire
yard and only my yard like everyone
else's yard has none of them and I'm
like they're doing something I guess
there's a thing you guys and then yeah I
figured out yeah there's like a
treatment you have to get so it's like
I've just so then I was just like uh I
was like all right we need I figured out
we need them to come every week and then
we need them to just like do whatever
the thing is that needs to be done
because I don't know it's like the
herpes of the suburbs yeah yeah well
it's like and it's like there's all
these things that you just don't know
like you don't like I knew I always knew
about cutting grass like I was aware
that people had lawn mowers and that
grass gets tall and then you cut it but
then all of a sudden you start seeing
like little like you know brown patches
and I'm like where's the grass there
they're like oh you have to lay down
grass seed and I'm like I'm that's news
to me yeah I just thought it was like
and the neighbors your neighbors don't
like when there's dandelions in just
your yard and the grasses no one no one
ever said nothing but I do feel
I do feel like they're like I bet he's
on that are you garbage podcast City
Slickers moving yeah huh okay uh what's
a vacation for you guys look like now
where where have you gone uh we
um last year we went to um what's it
called uh God damn I'm bringing her
something Ocean City Maryland no it's
it's like the it's like a sandals it's a
nice Town that's down in uh like in the
Jersey Shore area
Cape May Wildwood Stone Harbor Long
Beach Island Madison LBI I'll remember
it in a sec Detroit
the Bermuda Triangle is it something
springs oh no um Spring Valley Spring
Lake is it spring lake
okay here Long Beach Island or near Long
Branch yes yes I think that's right I
think that's right yeah okay so we went
there last year and then this year
um we uh yeah we're doing like another
another nice little town around there I
don't want to say it now no like I'm
going to be there this summer because I
don't want any crazy fans to come out
hey man we've been waiting we've been
waiting for you since the podcast came
out so you're doing Shore vacations yeah
but also just like I would do something
a little bit further again it's just
like my youngest is one my daughter's
four so traveling far is kind of a pain
is there a Disney trip in your near
future yeah I I know I was at my
four-year-olds already bugging me about
it okay but I'll wait I'll give him
another couple years I think maybe when
in like two years or something like that
right
right and then it's like uh you know
like her mom is like well I want to come
too when you go of course and then like
if her mom comes and I gotta bring my
mom of course
her dad's gonna he's yeah it's like so
it's gonna cost me 200 000.
sure it's like give me a couple years to
do some more let me do some more Road
dates before we do this or you can get
down there and pull your dad to move
this goddamn Mouse grabbed my ass
there's one person I could bring
don't cut that bill in half you guys now
first off let's talk sides what are you
guys doing here
[Laughter]
how many suits do you own and do you
know how to tie a tie
I could tie a tie uh I'm almost
certainly not gonna have it the right
length on the first tie sure there's
going to be several ties before I figure
out exactly how this this works together
I think I've I think I have two suits
okay name brand anything special or
anything I think it's a Brooks Brothers
suit I don't know I don't remember what
the other one was but that's a recent
you know what was that for uh the
libertarian uh party convention I think
is what I bought another suit I believe
that's I don't think I ended up wearing
it there but I bought it for for a
convention okay uh because I was like uh
I was introducing Ron Paul okay and I
was like that guy's my hero so I got it
very sharp but I think I ended up going
with just like a shirt and tie and not
the suit Rooks Brothers very very famous
it's a couple of books right there well
you know we've all come up a little bit
in this sure we're making a couple bucks
yeah I thought of this how many bathing
suits do you own
I think I only I think I have two two
maybe only yeah two is respectable I
think two just one is trashy that's all
right I think I got one I got one for
sure yeah it's uh you lost yours sure
did I had at a certain point I think it
might have been two years ago like
during the summer we were going
somewhere we were gonna go to the beach
and I realized I didn't have any yeah
and I was like oh swimming in like N1
basketball shorts and then I yeah and
then would you be okay with that
yeah that'd be fine
um but then my wife went and bought me a
bathing suit but she bought two she was
like
smarts know what they're doing yeah yeah
that's good and I can't sell you on
marriage with anything else
where did you learn to swim growing up
in the city
um great question my uh East River well
it's summer camp I used to go to like uh
summer camp and they'd always have like
a city summer camp yeah it's like a
Sesame Street I went to uh a YMCA summer
camp one year that was real garbage it
was a real garbage summer camp
um but even they had a pool in the Y and
they'd teach a you know you do like an
instructional swim I learned at a YMCA
as well yeah yeah
uh how old were you when you the first
time you went on an airplane
um first time I went I think uh I think
going into Disneyland I think uh or
Disney World I think we went when I was
like uh three okay
they did take yeah they were married
back when they were married the whole I
think we all went okay I'm pretty sure
that was the first time what'd you get
your passport
oh I remember I got uh
I think it was I when after I graduated
high school I went to Amsterdam with me
and a bunch of friends of ours we saved
up money to go literally just [__]
the trashiest [__] thing there you
know and so we went there and I think I
got my passport for that okay
respectable all right do you know how to
ride a bike
yeah that was big in Brooklyn when I was
a kid oh [__] that was normal yeah a lot
of city kids don't man oh man in here
really that was huge that was our whole
thing like when I was like seven eight
nine it was like bikes where that was
our whole world that was riding bikes
yeah huh
a what
he's just making [__] up now insulting
me a bicycle so two wheels you're
telling me let's uh let's cruise into
the bathroom of the new place you got
his and her sinks his and her sinks yes
okay in the master bathroom of course uh
and his and her sings in the kids
bathroom
got Dave they're uh four bathrooms what
or three and three and a half bathrooms
three and a half where's the third
where's the third full bathroom on the
the bottom floor so it's like uh the
house is um it's like a it's like a half
basement type deal you know what I mean
where because like it's kind of on a
hill right so it's a on in the back of
the house it just enters like the ground
floor okay in the front of the house
it's underground gotcha okay so and down
there there's a full there's a full
bathroom Okay then on the main floor
there's a half bathroom and then there's
two two upstairs hold on it sounds like
a nice giant is your kitchen on the
ground floor yes okay that's all I was
concerned with
sometimes now we can continue sometimes
they're on the second floor and you're
like wait what the [__] yeah there are
places that are weirdly designed like
that
um you take your shoes off at the house
yeah that's my wife's thing I get it
it's been that way since we were since
we were dating since we were living in
an apartment Italian world right Italian
they take their shoes off she's real big
on uh as I remember when we first moved
in together
um so before we married our kids or
anything like that and I was one of the
first times like we just got our first
place together and one of the first days
I just like went over to the bed and I
sat down on the bed and she was back
then like now she would just let me have
it back then she was like trying to be
all like I've never have I'm never mad
at you but she was like do you think
maybe we could not have you sit on the
bed in the jeans that you were just on
the subway and it was like yeah and I
was like I was like you know I never
really thought about that before I get
where you're coming from like there's an
article
yeah it's uh I was like okay but yeah
she was big on no shoes it's hardcore
but that's who you want running the ship
yes that's exactly I imagine she keeps
it pretty tight she's she keeps it very
tight in all types of ways
she's uh no she's very clean and which
is good because I'm like a slob sure
nature so it's good that she's clean
um in the bathroom again is the tub and
the shower separate yes uh but we took
out the uh the tub you did the jacuzzi
tub yeah it was like a big nice tub but
it just and it was beautiful and it kind
of looked like a nice piece for her
thing but she wanted to build like a
vanity thing and uh
and um it was like no we're never gonna
use this but I haven't taken a bath
since since I started taking showers I
haven't taken a bath and I'm not a big
bathroom again yeah I just don't so we
got rid of that huh but then in the
kid's room it's like a shower bathtub
all over one
construction after they moved in that's
pretty clean
fixing a couple of things there what uh
what kind of soap you banging with you
doing bar you're doing body scrub you
got a loofah what's give me to run I'm
uh my my wife has completely different
products than me I don't know what the
hell she uses but I am I stick with a
bar soap what brand I'm I'm doing Dove
now I was Irish bar for years uh until I
finally I hit an age where just every
winter I would start having crazy dry
cracking I mean like itchy all on my
sides in the back of my arms and [__]
Irish Spring will do that thing yeah
Irish Spring as well they invented it
yeah it was rough but that's what I used
to rock with all the time but so then
there's that uh now now I do the dove
it's got a little bit to moisture it
tells her that right on the on the box
yeah but I'm a bar soap guy I'm not like
a cloth body wash I could not make that
straight part of our skin bar to skin
okay how often do you wash the hair
every time I shower every time you
shower and maybe occasionally miss it
but pretty much every every day okay you
brushing your teeth in the shower no you
peeing in there no really really I know
I said that like I was disappointed but
I just don't I never do really you don't
brush your teeth in the shower when you
don't pee in the shower that's a first
and a long really I've never heard
anybody say they don't pee in the shower
I just I never do well it doesn't at all
I feel like it makes me pee like the
temperature changes I think I I almost
almost always pissed before I take a
shower I usually [__] before I shower
yeah okay I always try to time that you
know what I mean to be like that you
take a [__] and then jump right in the
shower uh be a wipe before you get in
the shower yeah yeah I'll do a first
round yeah I'll watch future president
of the United States
he can't be doing no white [__]
dumping jumps
you don't have my vote
let me grab another one of these yeah
that'll be silly
all right huh
yeah of course a gentleman of his
stature [__] what I don't know
oh it's right on the side of the it's
right on the side right there should be
met on a magnet oh there should be one
there too maybe or they're on the side
of the fridge there's a there's a it's a
magnet right there
we should just always leave that there
because we can never find it
huh are you flossing every day
no okay my dentist wants me to they all
see the dentist regularly I have been
since uh since I moved out since we got
this place
I've uh I found a dentist up there and
right with a lot of pressure from my
wife I have gone and I'm almost done
that's good but I've always I [__] I had
a ton of [__] oh yeah
yeah jammed up huh yeah I've always had
bad teeth now with that um with that
Dove soap is that something you'll go
pick up and purchase or does she handle
that stuff yeah no she does everything
that's awesome yeah I was like I
wouldn't have even known that inflation
was a thing if she didn't tell me about
it babe these prices are out of control
she's like you know these strawberries
used to be two dollars and they're like
twelve dollars now and I'm like I don't
know yeah I don't know what they used to
be I don't know we had strawberries uh
what kind of car are you whipping around
in
Buick Enclave
gentlemen but I don't drive no I've
never had a license I'm gonna get one
that's the question
never had a driver's license you're
right in the burbs the business is
driving she well I Uber or I need a
[__] Uber and then uh she's we got a
family car she does the driving that's
crazy yeah I know I'm not I I'm starting
to get insecure about it CityWalk City
Life I mean it just seems like a
hindrance on you it is you know it's
just uh this is Smith is a boss it's
just having the time to go like do the
lessons and do the permit and do the
whole [__] thing as I keep
procrastinating it but I do have to uh
yeah when the kids get older well yeah
yeah you're gonna drop them off here I'm
taking an Uber to school all right see
you later so you took an Uber in here
no I ubered to a train station because I
Uber home every Monday night so I try
not to Uber both you Uber all the way
yeah all the way I heard you talk about
that somewhere and I was like that is a
boss move what he takes an Uber home
well what else am I gonna [__] do of
course you know I respect it what are
you gonna get out of legion of skanks at
midnight and then I'm gonna go up to
Penn Station and kill 45 minutes and
wait for a train out yeah like I'm just
gonna Uber home sure you're not nose
you're not Uber driver is always really
thrilled or really pissed off I know
depending on what they're playing they
could hate it yeah they either or
they're like just the best thank you or
they're like God I hate this guy yeah I
had one guy got in the car and we had to
go all the way up to he was so mad he
was like I lit he like lived in deep
Brooklyn I had to go all the way uptown
to the Heights and it was like 4 a.m he
wanted he thought it was like I was just
gonna pick up this drunk guy he probably
lives in Brooklyn and I'll tell drop
them off on my way home and but it's
also man it seems to me the system is
all [__] up because it doesn't from
what I understand it doesn't show it to
them the location which is why I can't
that you just like let them pick if they
want to go there because then nobody
would use the service because people
would just be getting turned down all
the time I mean I think people still
would use the servers they just don't
want that well I guess they don't that's
just more time on the app
I see that but you're 100 right because
you know what they do they'll
park close enough to you where they can
look at it
and if they don't like it they'll cancel
on you yeah I've had that or like
they'll be like a minute away for 20.
I've had it happen just because it's not
it's never like that long so it just
doesn't bother me but I've had it where
like they call me and they're like hey
where are you going and I'll tell them
where I'm going and then they're like
hey I just I really don't want to go
there when you're going home yeah no
problem it's gonna be X amounts yeah
okay this guy's going far right so is it
worth it so but I have no problem with
that then it's like okay and then like
two minutes later something else
somebody else I don't wanna like someone
pissed off if someone wanted to go home
in 20 minutes or whatever well I do
think now they have uh I'm going home
button like my last this will be my last
ride to get them closer like that's good
it'll take it in the direction I think
huh you send in any venmo requests
um no
no
I don't think I've ever sent a venmo
request I don't actually I I don't have
a venmo doesn't have a license I uh I
don't I have uh PayPal and I have what's
the other uh what's the cash app no it's
the one that like works with Zeal
I have that
um but my wife has a venmo a few times
people have been like oh can I venmo you
and I'll just give them her [__] yeah
send it to her uh but no I've never
requested a venmo okay uh what do you so
what is a state ID yeah is that what
you're rocking with I got a New York
non-driver's idea I still I still
haven't changed it to Jersey that's
great well it's only been three years
man that's really gonna hang over the
score I gotta be honest with you he was
pretty he was kind of
driving a Buick around yeah hey [__]
rolls the roost this guy yeah this is
all like how you want to interpret it
you know what I mean
he does ride in the back seat though I
clearly come from pretty garbage Origins
oh no that's yeah but you also you know
called your way out of it you got a nice
three-car garage house you have a
[__] three and a half bathrooms you
read a lot I assume I I read a good
amount okay when you guys go to bed at
night is there a TV in the bedroom there
is a TV in the bedroom do you watch TV
when you go to bed sometimes do you
leave it on as you guys fall asleep no
okay it goes off it goes off yeah I
can't sleep any lights on when you guys
go to bed
uh there's like night lights in the
hallway okay I'll plug in things because
for the kids and stuff and we're rocking
a king I assume king mattress California
California King yeah how many pillows
are you using to sleep I'm sure she's
right set up she's got a ton of pillows
on there but I use two pillows to sleep
behind your head one behind my head and
one arm over yeah
I love to hug a pillow are you facing
out are you facing in all over the place
all over the place ceiling fan in the
room yes is that going
most of the time okay not always but
usually central air in the house I
assume yes good man
good man it's not a [__] [__] this
really does feel bad this show really
makes you feel like everything and
you're like do I get the job or not what
did I you just tell me are you gonna
call me
well we're gonna make our decision next
week Dave we'll let you know all right
all right do you dance at weddings
um fast dance you go out and mix it up a
little electric slime not that I
wouldn't
not that I wouldn't
but if like if the wife doesn't want to
I'm fine with that sure reluctantly but
if she wanted to then I'll we'll go yeah
sure what was the last haven't been to a
lot of weddings really I mean I've been
uh I think the LA I think Sal's was the
last uh that I went to okay I don't know
um
Gary veders that was a while ago I don't
know yeah would you uh would you drop
any envelope for uh what do you yeah
what do you give a guy like Sal
a couple hundred bucks no we got
something
that makes sense yeah right guys yeah
yeah you can't because you can't give
money hey Sal here's 400 bucks
yo now Sal money can change a man so
don't worry I gotta let you know
um what about the vidster do you
remember that what you dropped on I
don't even remember I was this that was
a long time ago I was pretty broke at
that point like I might have been like
here is half a 20 bag of weed
that's what I think we can smoke later
this goes I don't know if you're gonna
crack this thing open
if you plan to see some water next
spring you're gonna have a hell of a
stash uh if you go to a restaurant where
you ask for a different table if you
don't like it
I don't think I've ever done that okay I
don't think I've ever asked to switch uh
to switch to will you send food back if
you're like hey this is okay this isn't
right it would have to be extreme yeah
it would have to be egregious okay for
me to say the right answer bottle of
sparkling bottle of Stiller tap
I'll do a bottle of still you will yeah
yeah
that's what I'm talking that's even Clay
Street on the spark I know okay what's
the split and check situation
um let's say
would like you
the Mrs Lewis and maybe his lady go out
to dinner or something like that has
been those situations it would always be
uh if a situation like that a close
friend but like at this point look when
my before when I wasn't making any money
I was of course then it's just always
like you'd split checks and things right
but since then if me and Lewis and our
girls go out either me or Lewis will
pick it up it'll be like depending on
who gets there first
to be like I got this one yeah and then
it'll just be one person pays for it
there's no splitting okay [__]
gentlemen right and then I feel like in
general going out with like other people
it it almost always ends up being the
most successful person there it's just
like I'm
I'm picking up the check that's good
Circle well it just doesn't seem like
I mean yeah I don't know that just seems
like the way it should be sure funny
you're not wrong 100
classy answer right there
you have a go-to karaoke song
now I'm not a big karaoke guy I don't
have any go-to song man look at you ever
worn jankos yes I have one jankos yeah
yeah sorry I'm not gonna lie okay
chain wallet never a chain wallet no
okay what kind of snacks we looking at
at the house
um what's in the pantry uh and the
Panther's over you're watching a little
something on TV the kids are up in bed
um what's Dave Smith
obviously a lot of kids snacks and [__]
but I'm not like I don't eat that uh
you're not dipping into anything very
very rarely you know like and usually
that'll be like if they just like left
it out and didn't finish it it was just
out sometimes it's just there and you're
like all right well you said the oldest
is four yeah wait till you know a couple
years they start being gushers and yeah
no they're not on any of that okay [__]
it's like cheddar bunnies and as my wife
gets them all the like organic versions
of the snacks no I've I've had some some
leftover cheddar bunnies I believe but
it's kind of like you're about to throw
them out yeah Annie's you're about to
throw them out you're like all right let
me just have them they're not there uh
all right but
um what do you like sourdough pretzels
the hard ones yes the full pretzel yes
love them uh
I will still uh occasionally not like
regularly but I will still just get like
a bag of like Lay's potato chips and
just have like a big Lay's potato chips
in the house okay and they're just like
I mean the grease on your hands when you
eat them like you just feel it come on
man it's so good but it's so good
they're so good and it does it feels
like unnatural grease too for some
reason yes it's like they added like we
added it they put something there's no
need for it to be here and what what do
you have uh would you have a Diet Coke
with that would you have a bottle of
water I'll have a Coke old school OG
Coke I don't keep uh I keep the um the
little cans
yeah they're like not TW what 12 hours I
know what you're talking about seven or
something yeah something like that like
a little bangers but they're little
bangers because you kind of you know you
don't need like a full code yeah it's
great it's great I have way I have way
too much of those okay way too many of
them what color what's the booze Stitch
at the house we got a full bar yeah full
bar I'm uh I like having like I'm not
very I really just drink beer and
whiskey uh but I like having a full
thing you know anyway if anyone comes
over goddamn gentlemen well I want to
make you your dream if you come to my
house whatever if you two guys come over
to my house this week whatever your
drink is I want you to have I don't want
you to be like you know that's really
good this is what we have here you know
like I hope you like white Russians
on that note huh Kevin and I come over
to the house tonight
we asked for a glass of water or you
offer a glass of water what are you
giving us what are we getting we getting
a bottle we getting the bread well I so
I have some bottled waters Palm Springs
I got like a like a big case of Poland
Springs uh in the in the garage but I'd
probably give you I got like a you know
like a filtered uh
it's the reverse osmosis thing off the
side of the sink you do yeah my my
father-in-law put me on to that he had
it in his house and he was like this is
what you got to do no kidding yeah you
buy it and then you just got to replace
the filters I think like every every
year or something like that but it's
good but it's nice it's nice to have it
right there they say that's really
really good for you too it's like the
most filtered water if you look like if
you open the cabinet under my sink
there's like four [__] filters that
it all goes through before it gets there
yeah it is it's nice
that's real good you ever skied in jeans
I have never skied huh that might be
classy New York kid yeah never a thing I
also just uh I I not I don't really like
the winter
I don't really like popped out of school
because of it yeah I got I think I got
bad circulation like my hands get numb
very quickly okay I just don't have fun
like being an idea of like skiing is
just never appealed to me never skied
never snowboarded would you see yourself
retiring somewhere warmer like maybe
Florida or something like that maybe I
don't know maybe somewhere a little
lower taxes
Puerto Rico Austin I do hate taxes
just when we're getting ready to wrap up
I get them all wound up with [__]
Liberty now you know the income tax was
passed in 1914. illegally
might I add
what's your fast food will you have any
I uh dude I did I ate McDonald's like a
couple months ago
and it dude it [__] me up so badly
like I mean I literally I felt just the
whole day like from 20 minutes after I
ate it for the rest of the day I just
felt like I got hit by a bus but
I I probably will eat it again at some
point like I just can't uh I like uh
I like some of the kind of like better
fast I mean like you know like that I
don't know you call Shake Shacks
casual but it's like it's just so good
that's that's delicious but like uh but
I'll still talk about guys in the mud
Arby's Wendy's I like a Wendy's I like a
uh what is it the spicy chicken sandwich
from one store like that I love KFC
really still love KFC okay I don't eat
any of that a lot but I still it's still
my heart what do you guys eat at the
house do we sitting around uh the table
and eating at the dining room table or
kitchen table yeah all the time
in the living room
no I don't think I don't think I've ever
eaten are you allowed to eat in the
bedroom could you bring yourself I'll
bring I'll bring snacks and you bring
your snacks upstairs in the bedroom oh
yeah it's kind of not to take a plate
full of food like no I agree and I was
just saying I know them you said the Mrs
runs a tight ship well she's you know
like she's uh listen I run the ship
you can't even drive
she'll leave you at the train station
she's doing that thing where she keeps
pulling away a little bit Jason well I
do I joke about it with her that I was
like uh I was like I was like you know
I'm not cheating because I would need
you to drive
you drop me off at Becky's house you
drop me off at Becca's and don't ask any
questions please
um yeah I struck out I'm not sleeping
over come get me
uh uh but yeah I'll do snacks upstairs
and [__] no no I'll eat sometimes I'll
eat in the kitchen maybe not like go to
the dining room or whatever yeah eat
over the sink
yeah there's more like over the island
kind of thing yeah uh you travel a lot
obviously a little bit about travel and
then and then I think I'm pretty good
you TSA pre-check or clear no neither oh
I still I still haven't done either of
them I res I've resisted for years is
this uh I hate you know what I'm having
yours yeah I hate the idea of being
extorted and then paying them more money
to like not [__] go through their
[__] he's a man
I'm gonna fold on it
I also is that is that an anti-uh
libertarian thing of like no just you no
there's no like correct waiting in lines
come on what are we doing here fellas
there's no correct libertarian answer to
that you know it's like you're already
in the situation so you're gonna do what
you're gonna do uh but no I it is it's
it's pretty insane with the amount that
I travel that I'm not yeah I mean it's
hours hours out of your life okay uh you
sit in first class yeah
um not usually I don't think I usually
put the seat back in front I mean if
you're in the you know the if you're in
first class when it's like the big
planes of like if you're going to Cali
yeah um
but that's not like usually I don't I
don't know in the regular like seats
taking the shoes off on a plane no no
bringing food on the plane grab a
sandwich Bring It On
now I'll I'll eat I'll eat before I get
on the plane or I'll eat whatever again
okay we use the button to call the
attendant over
no I always I haven't done that in like
years yeah that's like before when I was
in the back of the plane I used to do
that yeah but also like you're in like
the 40th row or something you're like I
may not see this woman forever but like
when you're like in the second world
concierge yeah she's like right there
you're just like hey and they also when
you're in first class they come to you a
lot yeah they're just much better
they're always doing a lap yeah you're
bringing a book on the plane I can't
read on planes really I can't I'll bring
a book on the road like to read like
there but I can't like the bumpiness I
can never read on cars and planes
anything like that you're reading before
you go to bed sometimes did I ask you
that you asked them yeah sometimes not
always but sometimes
so there's a book next to your and your
nightstand you know uh there is one
right now uh but there's um but
sometimes I'll go down to like my office
and like do if I have to do work there
I'll do that oh yeah you're like an
adult that's yeah well it's just it's
all pretty new to me wait hold on don't
you have the office with all the books
don't you have the thing or was that
just a studio no no no no that was uh
this is uh I think what you're saying is
before I bought the house this was the
last house I was renting right that was
like where I recorded
like those like bookshelves yeah okay it
was like it was like The West Wing
Library
um Mayo Hillman's Miracle Whip
I got uh I got
what's hell Hellman's what is it called
yeah I got that's what I got in the
house right now okay my wife will get
that like avocado Mayo [__] because
that's what she likes that's classy but
that's the olive oil but I don't I I
don't like any of that I'm like uh I
also like yellow mustard okay I still
kind of like the regular [__] that I
grew up on
you grilling out at the house you got a
grill yeah cooking them up oh yeah I
just spent all yesterday grilling is it
uh built into with something the grill
or is it like a standalone Grill no it's
like a like a propane grill that I
bought okay and you were growing all day
yesterday you had people over my my
wife's uh uh parents and then her
brother and their kids all came over
it's not like that big a group what were
you doing hamburgers hot dogs ribs where
are you at did ribs which the first time
I've ever grilled ribs they came out
really [__] good they did ribs uh
some chicken and some sausage okay okay
how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken
I like I like a rotisserie chicken
because we'll do that we'll do that uh
every now and then grab a rotate like a
pre-cooked rotatory yeah yeah I love it
who's cutting the hair a wife wife got
started doing it in uh 2020 okay when
the lockdowns right away and then she
just uh my wife was also she was a
makeup artist for years okay she was
like so she's kind of like she was in
the world she was an esthetician for a
while so it's kind of like up her alley
that type of thing and then she just
like watched a few YouTube videos on it
and then she started cutting my hair and
I actually I just at the time I liked it
better than what my barber was doing and
then I just never went back after that
what credit cards you're rocking
American Express man I got an Amex who's
your who's your flight carrier who's
your who do you fly with United United
uh because I'm just it's uh okay I fly
out of Newark right there's just a hub
yeah there's like all the United flights
there so it's like the most there's
every flight I'd always end up booking
United so then I was just like all right
I'll be a member of that how do you feel
about the deviled egg
I uh I've traditionally really liked
deviled eggs I had one recently and for
whatever reason it was I as I was eating
it I was like this is the most
disgusting thing in my life but my whole
life I've loved them so I'm not I don't
know how to answer that question I would
say that's classy I have to I have to
have another one to like figure out
where I am with it yeah okay I I mean
I'm
I I'm not
do you bite your nails or you clip your
nails bite
it's not that bad I mean he's human at
the end of the day
false reaction just like makes a face
then click some pen and writes something
it's like your shrink writing should
have been like what do you what was that
bad or good I don't know what to think
that question
your toenails clipping the tone
no I'm right off
any mani pedis massages you do anything
like that no nothing never done any of
that [__] in my life you eat with a
napkin tucked into your shirt I do not
no
are you in the cryptocurrency
I I got a little bit of crypto nothing
nothing crazy I should be like more into
it because of the world I'm in but I own
a little bit of Bitcoin and then like a
lit a very little bit of like small
random and you got a couple other
Investments out there you got a little
portfolio going not much very little bit
so I was really just saving for the
house for a while so that was that was
my money went
hmm I I'm leaning
classes he's not it's not crazy he
obviously comes from a long lineage of
dirt bags there's no way around that
sure he's done pretty well for himself
his wife keeps him in check the license
thing ain't great but I don't even know
I don't even know if I can say you can't
say long list of dirtbags Mother's a
learned person a single mom worked her
way up got her PhD started her own
practice sure thanks for making me feel
bad about it I was trying to be [__]
funny and we got it right here come on
in
you believe his balls he's a [__] called
you hey Mark do you believe it this guy
Kevin said about you
um his dad's doing slip and Falls sure
you got your pop
ain't great agreed the biggest things
are the the license the license but
that's the only real drastic one hey a
lot of people don't have licenses yeah
he doesn't have one either uh I
appreciate that yeah not when I take him
on the road I'm drunk I need someone to
drive he's the only sober guy in the car
he's got awful bringing someone on the
road who doesn't drive yeah that's yeah
and he doesn't drink so it's like what
the [__] if you work hard that's very
true he's got the book next to the bed
he's got the osmosis water
he's got the office
Buick he's buying American
you got any fireworks at the house right
now no I don't good I'd like to I'd like
to though
won't send food back hasn't changed his
thing
what's your routine in the morning will
you get up make a cup of coffee and go
out like in the back deck or something
like that watch the sunrise uh I I wake
up usually I wake up with the with my
baby boy he wakes up first wakes up
being a great father you know wow not
great I wake up this isn't noon or
anything is it what time are you getting
up with him uh 6 30 something like that
six thirties up and Adam uh up well I'll
take him downstairs give him some uh
some breakfast
uh uh and have a a coffee what's the
cost yeah how are you making the coffee
well okay so I've recently switched to
uh I'm drinking a lot of espresso now
I'm Dr and this this was like an organic
thing that we broke our coffee pot my
wife dropped the coffee pot and it
shattered and it was like uh this was a
couple months ago and it was in the
middle of like uh it was snowing and
where I lived on a mountain it's like on
the top of the mountain so it gets it
gets snow very easily there and there
was like the roads hadn't been plowed
yet like I just snowed all night as I
wasn't even like I was like we got like
we can't even go out and get coffee
right now and then I was just like oh we
have this espresso machine and I have
espresso I've never used it before and
so I just like figured out how to use it
and then I loved it and now I've been
doing that a lot in the morning now when
you say you're having espresso espresso
are you making an Americano are you
having a little thing no I have uh that
you got I have like the little coffee
cups you know what kind of little white
chocolate yeah I guess I don't know if
there's like four ounces yeah yeah yeah
um no but not like that like you know
like that big like that um
and so I'll do uh like a double shot of
espresso and then foam some uh some some
half and half yeah
I don't want to hear anything
complaining about this this guy's
[__] crazy I love doing what I can
milk there's I mean I'm trying to come
up you are dude you're you're [__]
swinging above yourself are you doing
any artwork on the foam in the car
that I do not know how to dare I have no
idea how that starts it says taxation
without representation
doing don't tread on me
Universal Health Care with a circle and
a line through it
ladies and gentlemen Class Act 100 class
Mr Dave Smith look at that man thank you
buddy thank you very much buddy
fantastic uh you got any dates up what
do you got coming up you want to hit the
folks with let them know uh
comicdavesmith.com all my days I got uh
Kansas City coming up and then uh
hilarities in uh Cleveland and a bunch
of stuff I'm I'm on the road the whole
summer oh we got the big uh the Legion
of skanks theater uh run oh right yeah
in August so comicdavesmith.com for for
all that stuff shout out to part of the
problem shout out to legionist ganks
dash digital Network Gomez
Mr oakerson of course and of course Mr
Dave Smith buddy we love you thank you
thank you so much thank you guys I'm so
dude I'm so happy you guys are blowing
up so much
appreciate it thank you for having me
thank you buddy Kippy what do you got
for uh we're just announcing our second
leg uh the fall and winter dates uh it's
a big one game it's like 20 new cities
so get those tickets they're gonna go
quick some of them are bigger venues to
buy those uh gonna need that you know
what I mean uh check it out everything's
at ru garbage.com gang we love you and
we'll see you next week peace